[Music]
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
there's a crusade coming
[Applause]
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dream them
yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
pain
[Applause]
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something
none of your ancestors learned
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one you lose that
one too
arrakis is a death trap
is an extermination they're picking my
family off one by one
let's fight my demons
an animal caught in a trap will gnaw off
his own leg to escape
what will you do
[Music]
i know you
one day the legend will be born
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
[Music]
i must not fear
fear is the mind killer
my lord duke where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go go
don't move let me see it don't move amy
can you see it
okay ready
i love it that's super sweet because
it's terrible
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
the day of the monster uprising
was the day i lost everyone only a small
fraction of humanity survived to move
than a brown
i've been scanning for amy the entire
time
and now i finally found her oh hey amy
is that you oh my god
hey i've heard always amy's colony
85 miles it's an impossible journey
everything will try to kill you
don't fight just run and hide okay
you all alone me too you don't have to
talk about it
you wanna come with me
look down is that a samurai sword
yeah yes it is listen to your instincts
out here man
what if i have terrible instincts
[Music]
you'll die super encouraging speech
you made it all this way for a girl huh
do you ever hear the term fools
no amy i miss you so much we have lost
this wall
we could still take our world back
you're more of a survivor than i thought
oh that was awesome oh i feel like tom
cruise
the past isn't dead
james fate draws us back together
[Music]
now your enemy is my enemy
his name is saffin and what does he want
revenge me when her secret finds its way
out
it'll be the death of you
you can imagine why i've come back to
play
there's a young lady in santiago i want
you to meet you're late
when you're ready
she's a disarming young woman i get why
you shot him
yeah well everyone tries at least once
james bond
we both eradicate people
to make the world a better place i just
want to be a little
tidier
come on bond where the hell are you
harder to tell the good from bad
villains from heroes these days
if we don't do this
there will be nothing left to say
[Music]
hey bet they thought they're going to
get away with this huh
me brittany and kayla didn't make it to
the dance camp didn't the school call
you
no kayla's sick i kept her home this
weekend i was sure they were doing this
together you know they're with their
secret plans
no way why dad pull over it's brit
what are you doing here i'm going to
that stupid ballet thingy duck
do you think i could talk to kill if her
dad took her to the doctor did she call
me when she's back of course
you need to tell her dad that you don't
know where she is no
hey what happened to your face looks
like you got hit is there a bathroom
nearby
can we pull over now
i'm scared she can't be trusted to talk
to britney instead
kayla get down
where's your friend whatever this game
is that you're playing it's over
where's brittany get out of here i'm
going to the police
how do you want to do something really
bad
that's second-degree murder
there's something wrong with her she was
such a happy little girl
okay this friend her father came by the
house acting strange
did bernie ever talk about her father
she told me that he
hits her you realize your temper with
your kid
who told you this does he really hit her
no yes i learned from the best
whatever you want to believe
[Music]
don't what at me like that
here's the thing i like you i know your
diagnosis complicates things but i don't
care
i mean do you like me yes i do even
though i
don't have cancer make your move romeo
most teenagers feel like they're
invincible not the superman kind of
invincible
the kind of invincible that tricks you
into thinking tomorrow might be a better
day to start chasing your dreams
we've been through this just breathe you
are my best friend so you are morally
obligated to say nice things to me
everybody else out there is not my best
friend if everyone else doesn't like it
then
they're idiots and while there's a lot
that i don't know at my age what i do
know is this
we all have limited time tell me
something you never told before before i
walk through the door i adore
what you're facing is scary but you get
to decide what matters most
now the front door are you writing a
song
hello i was thinking it might be cool if
we did something that was just ours
[Music]
zach have you looked on youtube you have
20 000 views
you should be happy i thought this is
what you wanted it doesn't really matter
what i want because it's not gonna
happen
it's not fair please stop i have nothing
to give you no rings
no future nothing there's so much in
there that the world needs to hear
what are you gonna do with it
[Music]
this is insane just breathe a little
are you him higher yeah i'm zach
it's my favorite song
[Music]
in the end i just want to make people
happy i zachary zoviak i'm asking you
for as long as i can
this is what some people take for
granted others are fighting for
and believe me i'm a fighter
you're glorious dynam i am
[Music]
travel is the best education it's the
only education really
i just returned from two years in india
the stories i saw and heard are amazing
i'm gonna try you out on a fashion
assignment if you want me to learn
they give a pay cuts if you don't smile
you don't fit into your costume or if we
don't do the bunny dip while serving
i've been working nine hours with no
break maybe we ought to join a union
how about next time going undercover in
the porno business
those are too big they hide your
beautiful face they're perfect
those women and bunny outfits are gonna
thank you one day
i have a fear of public speaking what
dorothy and i have to say is too
important
not to say it this is the year of
women's liberation
a simple right to reproductive freedom
it's basic
we're here to make revolution not just
dinner we gotta stop
you're working from within the movement
now change comes from within
every minute is a chance to change the
world
where are you lesbians what are you the
alternative
i thought i would talk about why harvard
law school needs women
more than women needed how dare you this
is going to be a disaster
stop the bus you're broken down that
tire are we there yet
this isn't the first time you've had
knives thrown edges
why didn't i object get out and slam the
door you will lots of times
speaking your mind will get you in deep
trouble the truth will set you free
but first it will piss you off
[Music]
the road is messy and the way the real
life is messy
it leads us out of denial and into
reality
[Music]
it leads us onto our heads and into our
hearts
[Music]
and we'll do it a thousand times again
[Music]
you sound great yeah right what you're
telling me you weren't feeling it you
were in it
we don't need to put them all out
[Music]
your hearing is deteriorating rapidly
we'll come back till then lou we just
keep going okay no
lou let's play them all and see what
it's like okay i'm gonna be like a click
track you can play to me
[Music]
i can't hear you do you understand me i
can't i'm deaf
i'm dead
i found a place i think it's important
that you stay here with us right now
reuben
we're looking for a solution to to this
not this i need you to wait for me
okay you're in for me losing my part
you're it for me
okay you gotta wait for me
[Music]
trying to save my life reuben
the world does keep moving it can be a
damn cruel place
but those moments of stillness
[Music]
when this
[Music]
crappy mundane world
suddenly it becomes raining the
magnificent
[Music]
all the fear is gone
that place
will never abandon you
we heard your news juilliard congrats
that's incredible
you're thinking of my sister b she's
going to julia next year
what makes vivian the star just always
be there for you
and you whatever you are
what if i could be more but if i could
be great all i need is a chance to prove
myself
moira wilson was one of the finest
musicians
ever to grace this academy we have
decided to rerun the senior concerto
competition in her memory
i stole norah's theory book she carved
symbols all over the wall and threw
herself out of third floor window
she was brilliant the competition was a
big opportunity
i had to beat her
[Music]
on vacation
[Music]
you stole my piece i knew you were
jealous that everybody else does too
something's up with you tools i won't be
there to pick up the pieces
music is a blood sport
you really want that spotlight you
wouldn't let anything get in your way
not even your sister
what if i could be more what if i could
be great
[Music]
i never fit in
never could win this isn't the life you
wanted
though i tried and tried i'll be better
for you
i promise
i fell in love with country music when i
was a little girl when you let me hear
you play
but you're too scared to perform them
songs
[Music]
i received another letter
immigration and customs enforcement we
have a word to search does anyone else
here reside with you is there anyone who
lives here no
no one resides with you no other
residents hey
[Music]
they take everything away i don't even
have a name anymore
[Music]
[Music]
we already have one daughter we don't
need another one
[Music]
quietly into the night and i'll sing to
the light of day
quietly into the night and i sing to the
light of day
date of birth friday 31st of december
1937.
you're living with your daughter at the
moment yes until she goes to live in
paris
no dad why'd you keep going on about
paris she told me no i didn't
i'm sorry and you told me the other day
have you forgotten she's forgotten
paris they don't even speak english
there
dad i'd like you to meet laura how do
you do sir i say you're gorgeous
thank you i must say he's charming yeah
not always laura has come around and
help you i don't need her or anyone else
i can manage
very well on my own everything all right
who are you actually it's me paul oh
i live here what is this nonsense and
it's me ah that's yours your father
seemed a bit confused
something wrong where's anne sorry ma'am
where is she i'm here
[Music]
what's the matter dad strange things
going on around us
don't worry everything will sort itself
out
saw it in his eyes didn't know who i was
it was like i was a stranger to him
just did something to me i don't know
what she's cooking up against me but
she's cooking something up what are you
talking about dad
i'm not leaving my flat i am not leaving
my flat
this really is my flat
isn't it
you see the situation is very simple my
daughter is of the opinion that i cannot
manage on my own
i'm so sorry about this why she
understands
perfectly
it's important i explained it all to you
why you keep looking as if there's
something wrong everything is fine
i think she tries to do the best she can
for you anthony everything will be all
right
i promise you
there's something funny going on
[Music]
all you early risers day creatures new
lizards people of the sun
be careful out there sunburn cut off at
7 22 p.m and toxic level drop-off is
805.
the big heat-up happened it created this
desperate need for augmented day workers
and human cloning was born
do you ever go out there look at the sun
with your own eyes
you just take your lithium x like
everybody else
what is it that you feel you have failed
with
you're on premium three when you're dead
you'll be eligible for a total upgrade
i wouldn't want to live without you okay
is that such a bad thought
you can tailor your insurance spouse so
that maybe they come back to you
just purple there's nothing to do
baby it's already been done
calm down or it's gonna be very messy
why this is like i'm the only one that
feels this way
we're all connected are you afraid to
die
i don't feel any pain actually i i don't
feel anything at all
imagine yourself feeling better looking
better did you not think it was
dangerous
playing god like that
one person can set something in motion
and the rest of the world is never the
same again
[Music]
you